it feels amazing outside i love it you
know we have gotten through so much with
the weather with the smoke and the haze
and gusty winds i think we have earned a
wonderful southern nevada weekend so
let's get this party started we have a
mostly clear sky officially the
temperature out of mccarran is 62 but i
believe a couple of neighborhoods have
already dipped into the upper 50s and
when we have a camera that's this far
out from the city looking over at the
strip if there was any wind at all you'd
see the camera bumping around not the
case right now so let's go ahead and
check some of those neighborhoods
anybody in the upper 50s there we are
mountain's edge way down in the
southwest seven hills anthem at 59 so
you might think about a sweater or a
jacket walking the dog or
taking yourself a little jog
65 for downtown also at the air force
base we want to check nevada and beyond
because it's always fun to look up at
ely and go are you kidding me 27 degrees
up there in white pine county 56 over
the hump in peru
definitely cooler up in cedar city good
morning to you at 39 but no
precipitation that is well off to the
east of us we're going for 84 today kind
of thought we would get there yesterday
we ended up stopping at 82 there's the
normal high for this time of year and as
we've been talking we are going to be
heading back towards that normal and
beyond but nothing like the record of
103 on the 1st of october in 1978
generally a nice weekend so here's this
area of low pressure the one that
brought us those strong winds it is
kicking up some snow in the higher
elevations of the southern rockies and
over northern new mexico and for your
family and friends we do have some
strong showers over much of texas weaker
showers through missouri arkansas
kentucky and tennessee and also up over
the u.s canadian border but man it's not
too bad all over the country let's check
out your eight day forecast as we
mentioned we are going to warm up now
overnight lows are supposed to stay in
the 60s but upper 80s for tomorrow
hitting 90 in some neighborhoods doing
even warmer than that in fact we may do
92 on monday now we are watching for the
extended forecast going to be a storm
system rolling in some of the extended
forecast computers are trying to bring
in mentions of rain we'll just call it
partly cloudy for now for now and keep
an eye on it